books hello my beautiful friends I read
400 books last month I know just a
little bit under my reading go I put all
the books I read into an Excel
spreadsheet and created a fancy graph
and you know all those book series
you've been begging me to finish I did I
finished them twice I also did my taxes
early and I know what you're thinking
how do you read so many books well it's
because I'm better than
you hey guys I read
um three books I remember half of one
and yes two of them
wor Stoner I Tried reading a literary
classic that was way out of my league I
read only a third of it and then got
really sad and to those of you who want
me to finish that series I
started I'm trying man this is a call
out video to myself mostly what are you
looking at no seriously what are you
looking oh that's nice what is that let
me tell you advertisement I have teamed
up with the most powerful booktubers on
this platform I'm talking Peru's project
Murphy NEP here petrick Leo and Daniel a
league of super villains you might say
you might also say Jake are you even a
booktuber read the description we worked
with wildc crown Productions the team
behind wraith marked created to
customize and design these pins for you
guys these pins were illustrated by
Christina Hassan and colored by Heather
Shield I actually loved working with
Christina so much on these designs that
I invited her to design our merch which
is gone now it's gone the merch drop is
over for now so right now the only merch
we have is this are black and white hard
enamel on gold plating and they look
amazing alone or together there's a
double clasp on the back to stop them
from falling out and a backfield logo
just to make them pop even more they're
$15 individually plus a small fee in
shipping and handling but they're only
$10 each if you buy all five the pack
also comes with a bonus Bookworm pin
that's not only exclusive to this
project but serialized so it's Unique to
you pins are discounted on this campaign
so now is the time to get them there's
also one run so once they are gone they
are totally gone I got to discuss with
Christina exactly how the pin should
look out of 1930s Art Deco I really love
how it came out I love most of these
YouTubers and I'm really excited to be
collaborating with them on this unique
pin project hope you're all having a
good day bye-bye go watch my book video
bye-bye